I don't know about you but I think the eigenfaces example for PCA is really,
really cool, and I like it enough that I'm going to have it be the basis
of the coding exercises you'll be doing in this mini-project for the PCA lesson.
So what I'll do is give you the eigenfaces code, and
point you towards some of the places that I want you to play around with,
say the number of principle components that are being used.
Or to figure out what the eigean values are for
the various principle components.
So, at the end of this mini lesson, you're really familiar with the PCA code.
And you can go in really quickly and
identify where all the important moving pieces are.